d-rose US is congressional correspondent
to discuss the changing role of women in
the United States we have with us two
distinguished members of Congress
representative Martha Griffiths Democrat
of Michigan and representative Patsy
Mink Democrat of ye mrs. Griffiths who
has served in the House of
Representatives since 1955 chose after
19 years of service not to run again for
reelection a lawyer she has served on
the powerful House Ways and Means
Committee the only woman ever to have
served on that committee she has also
been a member of the Joint Economic
Committee before coming to Congress she
served in the Michigan State Legislature
and was also a judge mrs. mink has
represented Hawaii in Congress since
1965 and was recently elected to another
two-year term by a wide margin of votes
also an attorney she serves on the House
Education and Labor Committee and the
interior committee before coming to the
House of Representatives
mrs. make served in the Hawaii
legislature and lectured on business law
at the University of Hawaii welcome
thank you in recent years women in the
United States have begun to organize
themselves to improve their status in
society what do you think has caused
this movement this women's movement or
women's liberation movement as it's
sometimes been called I think one of the
things has been that there's so much
better educated secondly so many more of
them have been forced by economics of
necessity to go to work
and when they have gone to work they
have discovered the tremendous
discriminations against them then having
discovered those they have discovered
the tremendous discriminations against
them when their homemakers and this I
think is the real route what do you say
that was right Patsy I think that's
probably true especially for instance in
Social Security which you've been such a
marvelous leader in calling attention to
the people in the country the
discriminations against women in that
law there I think that
because the women have not until
recently reached retirement age after
having work two full lifetime only now
are beginning to realize that there is
inequity in the law and have graphed
these matters to the attention of the
people back home and this has created a
greater interest I think in politics and
government how is there inequity in the
Social Security Law mrs. Griffith is
well a man a woman's husband cannot draw
on her Social Security and until I was a
member of ways and means even if she had
been out of the workforce for a year and
a half even her own children couldn't
draw if she died but I think one of the
really incredible inequities came from
an attention the other day a woman who
had worked for 35 years under Social
Security went to draw her Social
Security and they asked her if she had a
husband and she said yes but he was
killed in World War two so they said
well was he under Social Security and
she said I believe he was and she
brought in the number he had worked 18
months under Social Security and she had
paid in for 35 years
she drew more money under his
entitlement and she would have under
owned now I think that is absolutely
awful
well why doesn't the tax writing
committee of Congress the Ways and Means
Committee do something about this well
we need more women on the committee
that's really that we've been working
very hard but you see this is where the
discrimination lodges I have tried to
twist this whole business in a man's
mind so that they would appreciate that
what we are complaining about and so far
as a woman working all her life and not
being able to leave her benefits to her
husband is a discrimination against the
man of course but you see the men in the
Congress of well I don't need my wife's
support or benefit all I'm capable of
working and it's this mentality that
prevents them from seeing that the basic
law is is wrong and that we
should not be taxed then if they can't
leave the same benefits to their
husbands we're working on it we're just
at the very beginning stages I think of
this whole movement to reawaken the
sense of equality in this country isn't
one of the main purposes of the movement
to give true equality to both men and
women not only tours not only to women
of course that is exactly what the Equal
Rights Amendment would do for instance
in this country the way for a woman to
be supported at the taxpayers expense
is to get rid of her husband and then
take her children down and go on welfare
but her husband couldn't do that no
matter how great his need in many states
he cannot draw aid to dependent children
for his children which is of course
nonsense if they need something they
need it just as badly now the law is
even sillier in that having got rid of
the legitimate father of the children
and her married husband and gone on
welfare then if she marries again and
this would be true even if she married
Rockefeller those children could remain
on welfare you know you can't explain it
why do you want to pay her if she's
gotten rid of her husband take care of
the children with a stepfather if you
won't do it with your own father the
Equal Rights Amendment which you really
marshaled through Congress after it had
been introduced I believe since 1923
right but it never got through Congress
until 1972 largely due to your efforts
what exactly will it do what it will
really do is to force government's when
they make a law or pass a regulation or
whatever they may do to make it apply
equally to both sexes they cannot
discriminate on the basis of sex alone
they would not be able to discriminate
again in Social Security they wouldn't
be able to discriminate even in the tax
system
at the present time single people pay
more taxes on exactly the same in God
than married people but since this Falls
most heavily upon women they would have
to change it because it is a sex
discrimination we also have these lovely
little things in the pension laws if a
company has a pension and it's
integrated with Social Security they do
not have to pay anyone a pension who
makes less than $6,000 or who makes less
than $6,000 why women of course when
mrs. Griffith until we Congress passed
the equal rights in them and of course
it still must be ratified by
three-fourths of the states to become
part of the Constitution and five states
still have to ratify it for this to
happen but until the passage of the
Equal Rights Amendment was there no
protection for women under the law in
our Constitution not really
they never applied their 14th amendment
to women they didn't apply the 15th when
the 15th amendment had been written
which said every citizen could vote in
the name of heavens why couldn't women
vote why didn't you why did you have to
have the 19th amendment well of course
the answer was they didn't consider
women people within the meaning the
court had to admit they were citizens
otherwise their own wives would have
been deported but they never really
considered them people what chances do
you see for ratification in 1975
International Women's year President
Ford recently said this would be a very
appropriate way for the United States to
celebrate International Women's year for
ratification of the it will be ratified
this in my five in 1975 that will be
ratified mrs. minkyu introduced a very
far-reaching bill in Congress involving
women women's rights in many areas why
would such legislation be necessary if
the e ra is ratified well it was
introduced largely pending
their ratification it seemed to me that
we still need it to focus on the major
inequities that existed in federal law
so that people would not forget of the
basic reasons for ER in the first place
as Martha indicated if er a is ratified
and what it is the changes for instance
in Social Security will just have to be
made otherwise it will be litigated and
I would hope that the Congress would
just get about the business of repeating
some of these laws before the actual
ratification but when it occurs it will
be an absolute necessity in my state for
instance we were the first to ratify er
a following that we have had to take a
systematic look chapter by chapter in
our revised laws and make all the
changes it just doesn't occur
automatically and so the status of
women's Commission for instance in my
state has made it their number-one
priority to just cleanse the laws of
everything they regard as being sex
discrimination this does not happen by
and of itself merely because we have
ratified er a or have a provision
similar to it in our state constitution
and so I suppose the honor of us bill I
put in would serve that purpose even
after ratification so what you're saying
is the Equal Rights Amendment applies to
federal law but then we have the states
have eyes also to state law oh it does
it applies at a local level to the local
school board can no longer say that in
the case of a depression first all women
teachers will be fired or all married
women will be fired and then will fire
the men it applies anyplace where
government acts with the knees or the
government acts but it would not apply
to private business that's right it does
not apply to industry so no what what is
the United States doing in this regard
well we have the 1964 Civil Rights Act
that applies to them and then of course
the in the higher education bill of
several years ago applied to women is
that right could you discuss that mrs.
Newton
yes that was with reference to any
policies and regulations
hiring this includes hiring firing
policies of the education departments
and the local communities as well as
universities this is a very important
step forward and quite complicated and I
guess there is a growing awareness among
educators that they haven't been
entirely fair
not only and who becomes an
administrator and who gets to be
principal and who gets to be the deputy
superintendent of curriculum but
generally in the way they have
administered their educational policies
so I'm fully in support of the amendment
that we put into the higher ed bill and
then of course this past Congress the
women's educational equity Act which was
a bill that you sponsored and worked
very hard for was recently signed into
law could you talk about this the need
for this legislation yes it's always
been my belief that no matter how many
laws we passed or how many
constitutional amendments we were
successful in having ratified that the
major problem in any society was the
attitudes that people grew up with or
were made to believe were secret
traditions of their civilization and so
long as any part of our society adheres
to a sexist notion that men should do
certain things that women should do
certain things and then begin to
inculcate our babies with these notions
through curriculum development and so
forth then we'll never be rid of the
basic causes of sex discrimination so
the women's educational equity provision
which is designed to provide monies for
small groups institutions women's
organizations school systems
universities whatever to try to a
grapple with this problem do some very
intensive work in curriculum revision
textbooks why do all the women for
instance in a child's Primmer
have to be a picture as homemakers with
the aprons on and the kid
never anything very exciting beyond
being a nurse the doctor is always a man
the lawyer the engineer the statesman is
always a man and this is the kind of
very subtle way in which in my view
girls and women are discouraged from
fulfilling their potential and so I
suppose the purpose of my bill is really
to free the human spirit to make it
possible for everyone to achieve
according to their talents and wishes
another subject which concerns you is
day care legislation could you talk a
bit about that problem in the United
States do we have enough daycare
facilities for children of working
parents well Martha could probably
comment more expertly on the only
federal program we now have for daycare
which became a part of the special
services under Social Security and it
dealt with those on welfare or potential
welfare recipients it's always been my
view that beyond that government had a
responsibility to provide educational
services to young children before school
age and that really we didn't have but
600,000 spaces in the entire country for
early childhood education and this was
far too few when there were already six
million preschoolers whose parents
either single or both worked and
therefore we were falling far behind in
providing this very very needed service
one of the problems that we have with it
is that the states or the bureaucracy
itself
I want to write in very special
regulations I remember when I was a
member the state legislature that they
wanted to have very special regulations
for the buildings which made it almost
prohibitive now in many instances they
want to have very special regulations or
what the child is to eat and so forth
and so on so we have great difficulty
with it but we do need daycare and we're
giving it most in
portably in this country to people i
some of the very poor can get it not all
by any means but some but then the
middle class can't get it at all they're
not given exactly the same basis as
others we if you're going to have it my
opinion it should be given to everybody
alike and we should make arrangements to
do it but it shouldn't cost the same
amount as sending a child to Harvard
don't you think that's really good one
of the things it's so difficult to
explain is that we have a daycare
program under 4a of our Social Security
Act those on welfare the minute Thormann
goes to work she loses that opportunity
for care for her preschooler and so
while we're saying the whole program is
designed to get women to go to work and
to be self-sufficient and get off
welfare it isn't a zone of course Oh
welfare program discourages women from
going to work the truth is at the
welfare program is quite Congress of the
Congress of the United States has done
for women and let me tell you it's not
good right we are saying to them when
you are caught in this trap you are
there forever
we by this means you protect jobs for
men theoretically of course you don't
really because if you just permitted
those women to have jobs and have a
decent way to rear their children you
would have a greater demand upon the
entire economic structure and we can it
well afford it what chances do you
foresee in the near future Congress
really grappling with some of these very
central issues that it already did Wendy
on the daycare question in 1971 the
Congress in a very prolonged debate over
the issue for four years finally passed
a comprehensive a child care bill which
was vetoed by President Nixon and set
back the whole program tremendously and
it's taken us until now
December 71 to to this current time
where we're now again beginning to
regroup and decide we're going to go it
again I think with the new Congress
coming in and many new faces many more
women involved in politics in the local
level there is a far greater awareness
of the importance of this issue and so
I'm looking forward to the 94th Congress
really enacting a bill which will be the
first for our country and really it's
it's almost too late most of the
countries of the world have child care
programs certainly all Scandinavia in a
good part of Europe and Asia have
recognized the importance of providing
adequately for young children it's only
our country I think Martha that has
failed to recognize this responsibility
perhaps in International Women's year
this is a good news I really grappled
with yes in the 1974 elections women
scored significant gains at all levels
of government in fact more women than
ever before were elected to political
office women have had the vote in this
country since 1920 why now are they
doing so much better what why not before
well I think one of the answers is that
they have never run in such numbers and
they have never realized before the
exact issues now many of them do they
are well informed on the issues and they
are running many of them are running as
Patsy and I did with the support of our
husbands I bet they are trying and I
think that it will change American
politics I always thought it was wrong
that women would not vote for women they
do but so do men vote for women and
there were no women in America in
Watergate and I think this was a big
help
I will change politics women's
participation in greater numbers in the
political arena
do you agree first of all mrs. mink well
yes I agree
I think well you have to recognize it
took us 150 years to get the vote yeah
and 50 years is really in terms of time
not a great deal in terms of developing
from the just gaining the right to vote
the important position that I think so
many women hold in their respective
communities we may not have the numbers
but I think women I really listen to if
my state is typical we have many in the
legislature and they are the leaders
they they are in the forefront of public
opinion in the middle of public
controversies they're not afraid to
express themselves and I think it's
going to make a tremendous difference
it's going to I think just shake up the
system and make it far more responsive
to the human questions that confound and
and confuse the electorate as a whole so
I'm really very excited by it
and like Martha says our difficulty has
been that not enough of run we can't
expect every woman because she's a woman
the minute she runs she's going to be
successful and that's not possible so we
do need to have the numbers in there
competing and given the numbers I think
we're going to be more and more
successful over the years and one of the
ways in which is it changes it is it
permits a different viewpoint on every
law I can remember that we were once
arguing some years ago over who was to
get the jobs in a particular make-work
program and one of the women was
suggesting that they'd be 50 percent for
women 50% per man and one man rose on
the floor of the house and said what do
you mean it has to be given to the
breadwinner
who is the breadwinner
the only real poverty left in America
outside of the agent are in those
families that are supported by women so
that that woman needs to have that
opportunity of that job but you see you
have to have some women there to
understand this many of the laws have
been made have been made on the theory
that men will always hold these jobs
there for the surviving Widow was given
us a pension I changed the law that
permitted it to be the surviving spouse
if Patsy and I had died our husbands
would not have gone
and our pensions but the men's widows
picked them up at nine o'clock the next
morning or finally we change that but
there were all kinds of laws like this
you both didn't have combined it seems
to me very successfully marriage and
politics what do you say to people that
say the two might be incompatible have
you done this well I think that's
probably the the most offensive question
that's ever asked because I truly
believe that men and women are equal and
that just as it's difficult for a man in
politics to have the kind of relaxed
family life and leisure situation in
politics it's the same problem for women
it's really no different and I've never
heard anyone ask a man how has it been
on your family I mean it's not asked now
because women are getting into politics
and the question has become more
prevalent you see stories in Time and
Newsweek on the suffering wives yes men
politician right but it used to be
Martha that only our poor husbands were
going on but it was a question with
regard to families and how difficult it
is to adjust I don't think our problem
has been any different than a male
politicians I agree with you and let me
give you one little incident we were
invited my husband died recently the
White House and my husband related for
dinner and my husband really didn't want
to go and I said well why not
he said because some woman will sit
beside me who will say and what do you
do for a living and when I say I'm a
lawyer he will say she will say and what
kind of law do you practice and she will
come very close to saying and how much
do you make and I said well when she
asked you that question why don't you
say to her and what do you do for a
living and if she says well I have eight
children why don't you say well I mean
other than that
you know why do you assume that a man of
a woman politician isn't doing anything
he's probably highly successful or she
wouldn't be a politician don't you think
it's right but it's infuriating when you
both got in into politics and actually
when you both were in law school was it
easy for you in those days was it
difficult do you think it's easier for
women nowadays trying to enter the
professional world so to speak well I
think it's it's just a new whole new
world compared to when I was struggling
to get into it it was really very
difficult I hate to say it but and I
won't mention the name of the law school
but I got into my law school on the
grounds that they considered me a
foreigner I got it as a foreign quota
someone in the law school had not read
up their own American history and hadn't
realized that Hawaii was annexed in 1898
and we were all American citizens but it
was very difficult getting into into
school and getting into the professions
I couldn't find a job and what all of my
contemporaries at home say oh my
goodness what you've done to politics at
holman you know wish we had never heard
of Patsy Mink
I'll say well it's because of all of
your attitudes that drove men to
politics if you give me a job when I
came home from Rossville I would have
been really happy this is the royalty
check each what would you have much the
same I am story I was married and my
husband was in the law school and for
some reason he rather that law school
seemed to think well you know he will
take care of her and it's all right in
fact they had the nerve to say in front
of the other women in the law school
there were very few
well mrs. Griffiths is the first woman
that's ever come here that didn't come
to find a husband and one of the
Schieffer girls and Whittier said well I
think you're right and as a matter of
fact I've looked them all over and I'm
thinking of transferring
I thought was very good but I originally
I you know
they had the attitude well mr. Griffiths
will see to it that she's alright she's
known being trouble which was nonsense
well you believe this is changing now oh
yes easier probably yes
I think the law schools in particular
very conscious of the fact that they
have excluded women capable intelligent
women who would otherwise qualify for
enrolment except for their sex and are
beginning to expand their admission
policies and more and more women are
having an opportunity for a professional
education in all fields not just law
what do you see as the impact not just
on women but also on men and children of
the women's movement well I think in a
way that the women's movement has been
or has been a result of the impact of
changing times that is more education
for women but more divorce in this
country women have to look at the fact
that they're going to have to be
responsible for themselves the old myths
just don't work so that I in place of it
being the women creating an impact they
are reacting to an impact I think in it
I think this is done a good deal for men
and in the country right it's given them
a greater sense of freedom and
independence well before they had this
notion that in order to be quote a
gentleman in our society they had to
have quote a dependent wife you know
that they would display at cocktail
parties and and nothing beyond that I
think now they're sensing their
responsibility and entirely different to
context and both partners in a marriage
I think are looking upon themselves as
people and trying to do the best they
can with their abilities of talents one
last question and we're running short on
time so it's a very broad question maybe
a little unfair to be asking it but how
do you feel that women in this country
compared with women abroad in terms of
rights and responsibilities
and of course I realized that we depend
on which area of the world we're talking
about but could you generalize well I
have had members of the parliamentary
body of developing nations in Africa
come in to me and say oh I can't believe
it we have more rights than the women of
America have and we were told that the
women in America had everything and of
course we have nothing like the rights
of European women I think that's
absolutely true even with the Asian and
continent so many people say to me well
with your Asian background and all the
Asian traditions how could you possibly
broken the barrier you know and I look
at them and I say really they're much
farther ahead in Asia they have some
customs that maybe you don't understand
but when you move those customs aside
but women are very dominant in Asian
cultures and lawyers and have a very
good mastery of the situation whether
they are out in the front may may be a
question or two but I think that they're
very important figures who make a
significant contribution in their
societies well thank you both so much
we've been speaking with two
distinguished United States Congress
women Patsy Mink of Hawaii and Martha
Griffiths of Michigan on the subject of
women's rights a subject which all
member states of the United Nations will
be focusing on during 1975 International
Women's year this is wendy ross in
washington